all right welcome back to the program
joining us now the mvp of super bowl 28.
there he is hall of famer and all-time
nfl leading rusher emmett smith emma
welcome back how are you man
man i'm good how are you guys doing
today doing good buddy we're doing great
doing great great to see you as always
um so super bowl week and you you played
in and won three of them what's the
first memory that comes out for you as
we get closer and closer to the big game
well in my very first suball it was such
an exciting moment and i had an out of
body experience
meaning that six years prior to 93 i was
sitting in that exact same stadium which
was the rose bowl with my best friend
johnny nichols and i was a senior in
high school
and i was out there watching the super
bowl the giants played the denver
broncos
and
and i'm sitting in the stands and i'm
watching this game
and i'm getting all excited as football
players would normally do when your
environment's like that and i turn to my
friend johnny i say one of these days i
want to play in the super bowl and i
want to play in the stadium well when
you go to an sec school at that time you
rarely have a chance to go out west
and play in a rose bowl because the rose
bowl was reserved for for the big ten
and the pac-12 or the pac-10
and so at this time six years later i'm
drafted by the cowboys uh and we're
playing our very first super bowl and it
happened to be in the rose bowl and
johnny nick happened to be sitting up in
the stands watching me play in that
super bowl so it was an out-of-body
experience it was such a great
experience because it's the biggest game
of my entire career at that time i don't
play it in state championships and
played in a few minor bowl games etc etc
but when you play
in the super bowl it's the ultimate game
of professional football far as i'm
concerned
you know when we think back to that
cowboys team in the 90s how great it was
it happened so quickly and when you got
drafted this was a one in 15 team like
what was your first thought about what
you were getting yourself into getting
drafted by a one in 15 team
i didn't even care i mean i was just so
excited to be drafted um in the first
round and what made it even sweeter was
i was drafted by the team that i've
always wanted to play for which was the
dallas cowboys so for me i didn't even
think about one in 15. it never dawned
on me about them being one of 15. when i
got here i saw jimmy johnson here i saw
irvin i saw what they were trying to do
i felt like jimmy johnson was going to
turn this thing around he was a winning
coach in college he had a bunch of young
players that that he was molding and
shaping into the team that he really
wanted to have
and i just bought into the system
brought into the program and they just
had a feeling and belief that we were
going to be pretty good i mean how can
you not be good when you have a
quarterback like troy
how can you not be good when you have a
wide receiver like michael irvin and
then you start to see other players
that you really didn't know much about
but you knew that jimmy was a winner and
he was putting together something pretty
special and once we started winning uh
when we went 11-5 in my second year with
north turner at the quarterback position
we gained confidence uh in ourselves and
not only that but we made up our mind
after we got beat by detroit
that uh we was gonna go further than
what we did this in in 91 and we came
back in 92 and went all the way to the
super bowl you know you talked about you
know 92 that rose ball experience
everything like that i could still
remember that old clip of like you and
michael irvin in the end zone talking
like before the game going man this is
big right i'm sure you remember but can
you talk about you know like your
emotions
before the game everything are you
nervous are you excited is your do you
want to throw up like how did emmitt
smith handle those situations you know i
had
major major butterflies um i i would say
anxiety was at an all-time high there
was a little bit of nervousness
underneath it um i mean because buffalo
had at that time had lost two straight
super bowls so the question would be in
the back of one's mind okay would today
be one of those days that they get to
get over that home right right and you
then you have to go back and ask
yourself why i'm thinking like that i
gotta i gotta say in this
and so i gotta put down
i gotta do my job and so but yeah uh
even
walking out of the stadium and walking
onto that football field um there was a
sense of
nervousness
but excited nervousness nervousness um
there was a sense of joy
because
you're playing at the biggest stage and
for me i've always felt like the bigger
the stage the better i'm going to
perform and so
and on this stage the world is watching
not necessarily just the country though
entire world is watching and you wanted
to give your best performance and
luckily for us buffalo made it easy
they took the ball over seven times
right yeah so
i mean that made it very easy yeah that
definitely made it easy okay so now like
we got you know brady and mahomes right
mahomes going to his second super bowl
this year you know brady going to his
150th super bowl but
can you fast forward to
like all right you talked about super
bowl the first one now it's the next one
super bowl you know the 29 or 28 against
the buffalo bills the one you're the mvp
of how much different were your nerves
in that game as compared to that first
appearance
completely different completely
different um
we first of all we knew our opponent
right knew him very well
and
completely difference in in the context
of the newness had worn off
and so you start asking yourself why
am i not as excited or as as emotional
as
my anxiety is not as high as it was
before well you come to realize
you've been here before
and it's like another game but it's not
another game and so you you have the
sense of calmness around over you and
you're going into the game and you're
pitching yourself trying to figure out
what's going on why why don't why don't
i feel like i did last year well it's
all because of experience
having that experience calm things down
to the point where
you're worried that you're not as
excited as you once were before and
that's when you realize that the game is
a normal game
and it's all because of experience you
just got to go out there and play and
execute and for tom brady who's been in
now 10
he's probably pitching himself like well
he's probably more nervous now because
he's with the new team
right and there's i mean he he's like a
new kid right now
so
but he knows how to play the game he
knows what his experience level is like
but it's different because he's with
tampa bay
he's he's char he's on he's in uncharted
territory and and that makes a
difference
last year emmett we had you on set and
we talked about your record and you
explained that you want someone to break
your all-time rushing record while
you're around to celebrate it with him
because you said how much it would have
meant to you to be able to celebrate
with walter payton and he wasn't there
i'm looking at the running backs in
today's game is
across the league is there anybody out
there that you've kind of flagged as
this could be the guy
who eventually
breaks my record
it's too early it is too early in the
game right now frank gore is the guy
that's still out there running and um i
mean he's inching closer and closer but
you know it's just too early to tell in
terms of all of the young backs that are
out there derek henry just came went
over 2 000 yards this year uh and so
he's quickly moving up the ladder
himself uh but it's just too early to
tell right now um i would start looking
at it uh when players starting to get
into 13 000 yards once you get to that
13 000 yard mark we'll see where you are
and how your body's feeling how you're
holding up and and and whether or not
the team continue to believe in you and
give you an opportunity to go and do
something pretty special
you know ezekiel elliott started off his
career very very strong and he's dipped
the past couple of years but he's still
playing well it's just he created a bar
in his first couple of years that's hard
to match where do you see his career
breaking as he goes forward what does he
maybe need to do to get back to where he
was early in his career well
one he has a whole year
to allow his body to recover from kovac
because he started the season off last
year with kovitt and no one knows how
kobe really impacts a young player's
body so he has a year to recover from
that and a whole offseason now to focus
on some of the things the little things
that he did not do so well like like
protect the football like he did last
year this past year he fumbled the ball
quite a bit so he has to learn
now go back to the drawing board
i think he's going to be fine i think we
definitely need to upgrade our offensive
line to give him a little bit more help
and i think having dak press got back
and and just the newness of
of of the things that uh we need to do
as an offensive unit uh to continue to
improve upon that offense uh during the
offseason is is gonna be critical
all right i want to go i mean listen i
grew up with you i mean you know you you
made me cry in 93 with the shoulder
injury game and cost
so i got to go back down you literally
did not cry when that when i ran over
you guys with that shoulder yeah i mean
i was known to cry after a tough loss
there when my dad's career every now and
then you felt bad for your father that's
what it was well exactly right there's
no doubt i wasn't feeling bad about you
i was no not at all
i was sick of you by the end of that
game but your three super bowl
championship teams which one was the
best one in your eyes
the best one was the 92 the 90
the second super year 93
yeah 93 team was the best best team uh
by far because of the depth that we've
had on our team i mean we
um
we were we were solid i mean solid i
mean we were very experienced uh ball
club we had upgraded in certain areas
and uh we just had everything i mean i
mean man we were we were good i know
very good well my dad always talks and
says that your 92-93 teams were the best
teams he ever played against in his nfl
career
um
i want to know what what your career
that that nfc east was amazing of course
the 49ers the bills all the what was the
best team emmitt smith ever played
against in his career
wow
best team yeah
oh man it's kind of hard to say that uh
because
i mean i know i can go i can go to best
defense yeah okay fine i i have a
feeling i know the answer to this one
but go ahead the best defense i think
i've ever played against was the
philadelphia eagles defensive buddy ryan
and reggie white i mean
that that bare defense that they ran up
against us the whole time to shut down
our run i mean i never forget my rookie
year when they sat uh troy aikman 11
times in one game
and i'm blocking my guy
boom he's getting hit i'm like oh what's
happening back there it was a meeting at
the quarterback and i felt bad for him
and so
but uh buddy ryan and that that eagles
defense in the early 90s was something
to compete against yeah
you know i think back to those 92 and 93
teams yet the chiefs win
on sunday all the talk next year will be
can they get three in a row do you think
you guys would have gotten to three in a
row if jimmy johnson and jerry jones had
found a way to keep working together
it's possible that's all i can say is
possible because i don't think we would
have had to uh deal with the
distractions that we had to deal with
um i don't think that um
i don't know if jimmy would have uh
let up off of us he would have kept his
foot on the pedal which probably would
have drove us all into the ground uh
because he worked it so hard
but i think the expectations would have
been there um
just dealing with things that we were
not accustomed to dealing with um
would have made a difference um i think
the work ethic would probably have been
there the focus would have been there
the commitment would have still been
there because jimmy would have demanded
that the commitment be there
uh but uh it's kind of hard to say but
those are the things that i think would
have changed i think with barry barry as
good of a coach as he was and
i respect barry so much
because the difference between the two
is jimmy had his thumb on the team
barry was a guy that said
you guys
have won
two super bowls
you should know how to prepare now
you are to be mature enough to handle
this
there's nothing i can say to change or
to motivate you to go out on that
football field and do your very best
you're getting paid a lot of money
i expect you to do that and you should
expect that of yourself and i respect
that because what he was saying is
you guys should be professionals by now
there's nothing i can say this thing is
already intact your office is still the
same your defense is still the same
special team systems are still the same
nothing has really changed except for
the person that's at the top making key
decisions when there's a need for me to
make a key decision
and he was absolutely correct and so
when we lost
we felt so bad
that i think every man on that on that
plane ride back
got refocused
it it hurt so bad and we realized that
we allowed one to get away and i think
that's the reason why we bounced back so
quickly and came back and and uh went
for our third one and ended up winning
that and we won that by a squeaker
because our team was not as good as it
was in those previous years
right i was there you're right
last thing because i know you got to go
and i want to talk about this tequila
you got your cell in here because i it
sounds good but oh baby i remember
that looks good i like tequila but was
that the most devastating loss of your
career i mean because that was a game
where
i i don't know i was a young kid i still
remember going i think you guys were
better you kind of just screwed it up
early on and got in the hole but was
that the most painful of your career
um
i don't know if it was the most painful
one
um
because i wasn't completely healthy
uh i was dealing with hamstrings that
year my hamstrings kept i mean when i
played in the nfc championship game i
had electrodes on my own
and and pads on my on my hamstring
getting treatment in between series
and uh by the fourth quarter my
hamstring completely shut down and i
could not function uh
as a running back i just couldn't do it
right um
and so
uh it was a disappointing loss i don't
think it was the most painful loss um
i i mean there are games i mean we got
beat literally you turned the ball over
painful losses are those ones when you
they kick a field goal miami
in the snow oh
fumble game that one hurt yeah we
remember that one yeah i remember a game
in houston in overtime when i fumbled
the ball that was painful
that was painful because i cost my team
the game
that is painful
um but the game against the niners i
don't know if that was
yeah i mean i said she had the tears
because i felt bad about not being able
to complete the game and be with my
teammates but i felt
reward because our team never quit
our team never quit and we fought to the
end and and that part made me very proud
to be a part of that team
emma tell us about that bottle you have
there and and give us the advice on the
best way to drink it
how about drinking that responsibly
that's number one
number two
number two
number two drink it with a bowl of ice i
love my tequila hedorah this is ultra
that i'm holding up right here they have
so many different brands legends and and
on and on but i like mine neat
with a with a ball of ice uh not glitter
cubes a bowl of ice or square and you
can have it in the margarita you can
have it in the blood and mirror you can
have it any way that you want it but
this i like mine's clean and neat just
like this just like it is right now i
don't want to add much to it so um
that's just me but you can have it the
way you want it you can treat it like
burger king have it your way
[Laughter]
both tequila drinkers so we'll get into
it
yes please do enjoy the game drink
responsibly and if you're going to
celebrate celebrate responsibly but make
sure that you celebrate with the right
type of tequila tequila had to do all
right
hey we appreciate you man great stuff as
always congratulations on all your
success we look forward to talking to
you again thank you guys
you the man
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports